the education secretary Jillian Keegan
welcome to you thanks so much
so teachers are being offered a six and
a half percent pay increase the teaching
unions have come on board say they're
happy with that and they'll recommend it
to their members but how confident are
you that teachers will accept that given
that it's still below inflation which is
8.7 percent
um I mean it's the unions really that
have got the best judgment on that and
and they they seem to be uh confident
that their members will do that but of
course it will have to go to the ballot
I do have um a couple of cousins who are
teachers who've been kind of keeping me
in contact and they all got in touch
yesterday and we're delighted actually
with the news so I'm hoping that they're
indicative of the rest of the profession
I mean you know teachers do an amazing
job they don't want to strike they want
to be in the classroom with children
they know that children need to catch up
they know there's lots of things that
they you know they're absolutely vital
um you know to our children so they do
an amazing job they want to be there and
and I know they didn't want to strike
actually as well so I think hopefully
with the unions recommending it um they
will be back in the classroom so they're
getting six and a half percent pay rise
it's more than had originally been
expected which may be good news for
teachers but there's more money to find
isn't there so our schools going to have
to find that money from within their
budgets or are you at the Department of
Education giving them all that extra
money so what's always difficult about
this is not the headline figure but how
it's funded and if for example you said
well you know this is the percentage but
you have to fund it out of your own
budgets then schools just simply
couldn't expect it because it couldn't
accept it because what that would mean
is a head teacher would have to make a
decision between you know giving
somebody a pay rise and maybe making
somebody redundant or canceling a
program or something like that and it
would just be
um you know really difficult for them to
do that so one of the things that's made
this really difficult is I've known all
along that whatever we offer we also
have to offer to fund not all of it
because there is some within the school
budgets that they were expecting and
they budgeted for but quite a big chunk
of it so in this case we've had to find
uh you know a significant amount of
money which we the department will have
to
um you know send to schools to to make
it affordable so how have you found that
money where's it come from from within
the department so what usually happens
in in budgets Within in the Departments
we have quite a big education budget we
do spend a lot of money on education
what usually happens is you have
programs which you estimate either the
demand LED forecast or how how quickly
you're going to deliver them and what
happens in in government budgeting is if
you don't spend it all and very often
you don't spend it all because you
overestimate how quickly you can roll
things out Etc then all that money
usually goes back to the treasury and
what's happened in in this case and the
treasury of work with us to enable us to
do that is they've given us the
flexibility to take those anticipated
underspends and to move them into
Teachers Pay so basically we've gone
through every single line every single
budget painstakingly I mean I've worked
in business for 30 years I've done this
a lot and we've gone through and we've
anticipated where we will not um you
know we wouldn't meet the forecast and
we will move that into uh into school
funding okay so if it's come from an
underspend that's okay for this year but
but what about future years as well
we've looked at Future years so we've
looked to this year and and next year
which are the two years that are left
within the spending review and then of
course it gets Consolidated into the
spending review and that's what happens
every year with everything actually you
know everything that we have which is a
real reoccurring cost every spending
review of course that's uh looked at and
you say that's where most of the money
will come from but schools will have to
make some adjustments themselves no we
have schools have budgeted so what you
look at in school budgets is of course
they have anticipated
um that they would have um you know some
pay Rises so they all um and this was
actually the problem when I very first
arrived in the department they'd all put
three percent in the budget and the
independent pay review body came back
with 5.4 that was last year that's the
extra two billion pounds that I had to
get when I very first started the job
now they've put three and a half percent
in and the independent pay review body
has come back with six and a half so
it's they have some which they have
within their budgets there's something
else we've done as well because I always
look at school budgets across the
average but of course there could be
some schools like maybe a smaller school
that's got specific concerns so we've
also we've got a school a school support
fund as well and we've increased that
um by 40 million pounds so that if
there's a school that's in exceptional
circumstances then we've increased the
money that that they can come and access
okay so teaching unions have accepted
the deal Junior doctors don't seem so
happy they've been offered a six percent
the British Medical Association was
saying yesterday that it amounts to yet
another cut in uh pay cut in real terms
Junior doctors ongoing strikes at the
moment Consultants do to go on strike
next week where's this all going to end
when the Prime Minister says there'll be
no more tall well we can all see
inflation no the junior doctors are not
unusual we have all got the impacts of
inflation and our household budgets and
you know every single person actually
across the world not even just across
this country has seen the impacts of
inflation and that is why we are very
focused on halving inflation you can't
chase inflation you need to get rid of
inflation so so they are not exceptional
in in having you know inflationary
pressures we all have inflationary
pressures everybody does but what we
have to do is halve inflation we have to
make sure and it's been really quite
quite difficult to do during these um
you know these times to to agree a pay
um you know a pay increase without
um you know having adding to inflation
so the government was suggesting that
any pay rise is over five percent would
add to inflationary pressure some of the
pay rise is going up to seven percent
since the government changes no it's
been very difficult to try and navigate
this and what what basically has been
key is not
um not having any new borrowing and not
raising new taxes which could fuel
inflation it is a tricky Balancing Act I
mean there's no doubt that has made this
thing you know trying to be fair trying
to um you know give public sector pay
workers pay Rises but also trying to
make sure that we have
um you know inflation this is not easy
it's moving around and there's lots of
driving factors underneath moving around
it has made it more difficult but I
would urge the BMA you know the
independent pay review bodies have done
a very thorough analysis and they look
at you know rates of recruitment
retention they look at all the other
sort of professions or similar
professions so they do do a very
thorough job and so you know I think
it's uh I think it's only fair that they
should look at that and take that
seriously okay we've been reporting
today on why so many children with
special educational needs and
disabilities are waiting so long
um for education and health care plans
they're deemed absolutely critical but
councils are only managing to issue half
of them within the 20-week time limit
it's a failing system isn't it I mean do
you accept that the government
underestimated the spike in in demand
and is failing this this system the
system is under a lot of pressure and
and the core reason it's under a lot of
pressure is the massive increase in
demand I mean our special educational
needs budget in the last four years has
doubled is now over 10 billion pounds so
it is under to pressure that's why we
put forward our special educational
needs Improvement plan which does a
number of things it invests in more
school places invest in more educational
psychologists more senkos so there is a
Workforce plan that goes with that as
well but there's no doubt there's a
massive increase in demand and we know a
lot more about special educational needs
you know we know a lot more about how to
diagnose various special educational
needs what we can do to help children
overcome them they're not getting those
it has put pressure on the system and it
is you know we are we are training more
educational psychologists for example
that's one of the key skills that you
need but also 5 000 more senkos we have
recognized that you know a doubling in
in four years is very difficult for any
system to keep up with
um but you know we do you know special
educational needs in this country we
take extremely seriously we have an
excellent system really but it isn't
keeping up with demand that's why we
have the send Improvement plan it's why
we're putting more money into into
places and into supporting councils as
well okay just just finally I do want to
ask you um we how putting out today the
latest in our Westminster accounts
reports and in that we've revealed that
MPS with second jobs have an average
wage of 233 pounds per hour that's 17
times at the national average
um it's all permitted all within the
rules but do you think those rules are
right given that teachers for example
they can't top up their pay are you
comfortable about the rules as they
stand now well actually teachers can top
up their pay with the national tutoring
scheme and they've been doing an
excellent job of helping children catch
up as well but um I mean I would imagine
that those figures are probably just a
small number of people who you know you
hear about these people you know get
lots of money for speaking engagement
it's average wage well but the average
will be I mean I I haven't I contributed
a single penny to that average I know
that I mean obviously I have two jobs
with the ministerial role as well but
the the reality is that's probably a
small number of people who are doing you
know speeches on the speaker's circuits
who are getting paid an awful lot
um and yes this is permitted and they
have to go through all the rules from
Parliament and it's something that's
permitted but I know that I'm not
contributing to that average okay well
Jillian Keegan we appreciate your time
this morning thanks very much indeed
thank you very much